observer le ciel où le soleil avec un
télescope ou écouter des lectures sur le
monde de demain
la commanderie se transformer le temps
de deux après midi en village des
sciences où de nombreuses animations
étaient proposées pour les enfants
autant que pour les adultes
le but vulgariser la culture
scientifique effectivement les relations
sa pote des grandes données très
technique mais ça il ya aussi beaucoup
de notions qui peuvent être abordés de à
tous les niveaux vraiment les plus
jeunes peuvent avoir des notions en
sciences sans pour autant qu'on commence
à les noyer sous les formules
mathématiques
cette année deux thèmes ont été retenus
l'observation scientifique et le rapport
de l'homme à la nature
l'institut national de recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement de versailles a profité
du village des sciences pour montrer ton
projet perception de la recherche
un projet autour des serres de recherche
de biologie végétale mais aussi une
exposition photo dédiée à la
présentation des activités des
scientifiques
au cours de la fête de la science
aujourd'hui ça nous permet de présenter
nos travaux qui sont effectués dans des
laboratoires de recherche publics et
donc de venir au contact de la société
est de présenter nos activités puisque
notre centre n'est pas accessible au
public donc on est obligé en fait si on
veut présenter nos travaux et de venir
directement voir les personnes sur des
animations comme il peut y avoir au
cours de la fête de la science par
exemple et les animations et activités
ne manquaient pas une vingtaine en tout
et de toutes sortes
on a observé le soleil et avec des
passionnés et c'est toujours cet échange
qui est très fructueux ma mère me dit
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
intéressantes sur le sur l'espace et
l'espacement deuxième chose préféré
après l'histoire et la mythologie elle
apprend des choses et quand ça bah si on
pose des questions sur seille commencera
d'autres activités sont organisées dans
les médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines
la fête de la science se terminera jeudi
15 octobre